hello everyone and welcome to round six
of the 2022 vedic candidates tournament
it is yanni palmichi versus young shisht
of duda and uh
this round has been absolutely
incredible we could show uh pretty much
uh
any of the games that were played and
we're gonna show most of them probably
but we are starting with this one as jan
is leading the tournament so uh we have
to see if he uh if he will continue
pushing or will someone uh stop him on
his quest to challenge magnus for a
second time in a row and uh that person
for this round is young shisht of duda
and it's uh it's a beautiful game now
all of the games are crazy in this round
so you guys will enjoy it
and you guys mentioned in the comments
that you would like some photos of the
players so here it is i don't show as
many photos as i used to as uh
a few years ago uh you know the the
photos were just uh much much weirder
and there was so much uh
at the sea but here it's just like
nothing not all that much is happening
like there's no uh you know no weird
shoes no weird pants no no funny uh i
don't know jackets no no weird stuff on
the on the board uh so
or maybe it's just me maybe i just don't
um uh see it that clearly if you guys
can spot anything weird uh you know uh
however uh
vague uh please do share so we can all
enjoy it but you know it seems like a
perfectly perfectly normal photo but uh
getting back to the game jan has the
white pieces and for this game he
prepared the retti opening so knight to
f3
uh duda replies with the d5 uh we have
g3 and now bishop to g4 duda goes for
the keras variation uh he wants to put
his pawns on light squares very early on
and get his light square bishop
out of the cage so he can you know focus
uh uh
on his development without having to
worry about how you're gonna develop
your light square bishop later on so
bishop to g2 and now pawn to e6 uh we
have castles and now knight to d7 we
have h3 challenging the bishop and the
bishop to h5 and here just a nice d4 we
have knight to f6 pawn to c for end pawn
to c6 again uh this position has been
played many many times c captures uh e
captures on v5 and knight to e5 grabbing
this beautiful central square and
usually you never want to capture on e5
because then white just gets a pawn to
e5 and this pawn will just be
uh you know a whole lot to deal with it
will be controlling many important
squares so it's just a bit better to
maybe not touch it unless you know
exactly what you're doing and that's
exactly what duda does you could also
play queen c7 maybe knight to e4 but
duda decides to trade captures captures
and now knights to e4 uh knight to d2
and here another trade captures captures
and the bishop to c5 now nicely
developing the bishop preparing the
castle and there is a game where queen
the c2 was played in this position but
here nepal plays rook to c1 and it is
now as of move 13 that we have a
completely new game so let's see how do
that continue so you could move the
bishop but it's better to continue
developing so queen to e7 defending the
bishop
and now uh king to h2 makes sense you
want to get the king away from this
diagonal so you can start pushing with
f4 g4 f5 and so on so it uh
it's very interesting whether duda will
castle king's side but he does he's not
worried of those of those pawns uh and
now uh ponte g4 you might be expecting
pawn to f4 right away but nepo starts
with g4 bishop to g6 and now f4 f5 if
not met properly will trap the bishop so
do the plays h6 he has to make a little
bit of breeding room for the bishop and
now queen to e1 uh you could start
pushing right away but nipple says
there's time for that let's uh first
activate the queen
rook f the e8 and now queen to g3 bishop
to h7 and now pawn to h4 so just
continue pushing this is a very very
healthy pressure nipple is creating and
but you know if uh i played the
perfection of course uh it's it's
nothing to worry about but uh it's never
you know anything to worry about if you
play it to perfection so here rook 8 d8
and now pawn to g5 now you could wait
with pawn to g5 obviously you could
always wait with any pawn push uh but
it's there just aren't all that many
moves uh that you can play to improve
your position like if you want to maybe
put the bishop on this diagonal black
and just to very easily grab a temple
with d4 then you know you haven't really
improved your position maybe putting the
bishop on f3 before doing that but um
other than that the g5 just makes sense
so this is what nipple goes for
and this is the
the turning point of the game i believe
uh we could pinpoint any moment in the
game but i believe this one is the
crucial one uh because here the absolute
best move is king to h8 and it's a funny
move to play
but uh of course you can't allow g
captures on h6 while the king is on g8
uh that that just would be silly however
after king to h8 it's not easy for uh
for for nipple to find moves here if g
captures we're just gonna play g
captures now black will enjoy the open g
file uh might even double up rooks and
the g file so king the h8 would be very
very tricky for for white to handle
however after h captures and g5 it does
not appear to be as tricky h captures
and g5 now bishop to b4 do the trades
off a pair of bishops but
nepo says that's perfectly fine captures
captures and pawn to f5 now and this is
just uh
well almost impossible to calculate
every pawn push what happens um and
there doesn't appear to be a move that
black can play uh so one of the pawns is
marching forward most likely it will be
the e6 pawn and you just have to
you just have to accept that as you've
allowed this by not playing king to h8
so here duda grabs a pawn queen captures
on b2 and now uh you could still wait
with rook to c3 rook to f3 to put more
pressure before pushing pawns but nipple
says no need let's just start pushing he
goes for pawn to e6 and okay f captures
on e6 and now pawn to g6 that's the
that's the good stuff we're gonna win
the bishop here uh uh here uh uh or or
even more interesting if you play f6
which looks incredibly scary because
okay everyone can win a bishop this
would be uh this would be pretty bad
because after rook to d7 there just
isn't a good move for white anymore uh
if you play g6 now uh now we can play g
captures on f6 and after uh capturing an
h7 so yeah you still win a bishop king
h8 and now uh it is the white king who
might run into some trouble here so okay
uh g6 right away by nipple uh we have uh
e captures on f5 g captures on h7 with
check and the now king the h8 uh king to
h7 also uh playable and it is the in
fact the engine's um uh first choice but
uh who who would play this uh that
that's not a move a human can play so
king to h8 and now we have rook to b1
and this is uh the only move that allows
um unable to create some chances here
because you are going after the b7 pawn
and then of course after the g7 pawn so
queen to f6 and not
you could maybe grab another pawn but
you also might need your queen to help
out with the defense of the king so rook
captures on b7 and here uh rook the e5
appears to be the uh a way to maybe keep
the tension rook the other rook is
coming to e8 so we can double up here
however do that boldly goes for rook
captures on e2 and now nipple just says
all right rook captures an f5 that's uh
what i'm playing you can't capture
because you get checkmated so what is
your move so of course uh queen to h6
check the only good move king to g1 and
now rook captures on a2 grabbing another
pawn and now duda has a past a pawn a
past c pawn a pass d pawn and if he can
defend
against nepo's attack who is up a piece
uh he he will have a great game so rook
b the f7 now preparing rook to f8 this
would be again devastating so rook to a1
with check and bishop to f1 again the
only uh move that does not allow do that
uh
to force equality uh is bishop to f1 and
now uh it's a move 32 both of them have
21 minutes on the clock so they still
need to make eight more moves to reach
time control but it's very very
difficult for duda to make moves or
rather it's not difficult to play moves
because you don't really have all that
many of them he starts pushing the pass
deep on
but now rook to g5 because by playing d4
you're not just pushing the pawn you're
also threatening queen to e3 with check
which will force a queen trade and then
yes white is up a bishop but all of
these past pawns uh we will have
something to say about that bishop so
rook g5 not allowing queen to e3 and
also now you're just uh enjoying your
triple attack under the g7 pawn so how
can you play this uh there really isn't
a good way that duda tries queen to d6
uh now offering a queen trade also uh
might have some ideas of going to a3
later on as you'll see
and now queen f2 of course again
declining the trade uh you could also
play queen to g for nepal decides to go
queen to f2 queen to a3 and queen to a3
an extremely uh poisonous and powerful
move if uh if nepal makes even a slight
inaccuracy here and i will just show you
for example if you play let's say rook f
captures on g7 and it makes sense you
get rid of that pawn next you're going
to play rook to g8 and win the game
it's actually a force to draw because
this is what duda had in mind queen to
e3 and now how do you play this if rook
g8 check we just capture on h7 and now
your queen cannot move your queen is
pinned so now if you capture the rook
here then do the plays rook a queen
captures on g5 with check and also
attacks the rook on d8 so here you would
have to capture an e3 but after the
captures and the rook captures on the e8
it seems like white is again winning uh
you are up a rook and the bishop however
there is pawn to e2 and that's what what
the duda had in mind now you have to
play rook to f8 there's really no other
way to survive this you allow black to
grab a queen and now let's say rook to
f3 and the game continues you are
threatening checkmate but after queen e6
guarding h3 it might even be black will
be pushing this game so this is what
duda prepared however nipple uh
obviously very very serious and in very
top condition in this tournament does
not allow any of this he just plays rook
to g3 and he was in this position on
move 35 that young shisht of duda
resigned in the game and another
brilliant victory for ianni pomnishi in
round six of defeated candidates
tournament 2022 which brings him the
total of three
victories out of six games that is just
incredible and even though that uh game
six against magnus was the turning point
in the match game six for him in the
candidates tournament seems to be uh
well just extending his lead he went
into this round being the leader of the
candidates and now by winning another
game uh he uh maintains that lead uh so
here you you resign there there is no
good move you can make your queen is
hanging you can threaten a queen trade
also the rook here just nicely guards
the e3 square so whatever you play you
you're going to move the queen or you
can play d3 you push the pass pawn now
we just play uh rook captures here and
there is no counter play let's say pawn
to no no there's no move you can play is
just such a silly position uh
without uh without even a possibility of
creating some chances here that that's
how bad it is
uh so yeah after rook the g3 uh duda
resigned and the brilliant brilliant
victory for yanipanishi uh who like i
mean like i said maintains his lead uh
after round six of the feeder candidates
tournament so really good stuff we'll
see if nipple can you know push like
this all the way and really what went
wrong in this game it's it's a very very
hard to pinpoint um obviously the
opening choice by duda maybe not uh you
know the absolute absolute top that the
you know the current engines recommend
maybe he tried to use it as a as a
surprise for
uh for nipple but it was actually nipple
who
who played rook to c1 which was a new
move in the position so
he wasn't really all that surprised and
it was duda who was wasting more time so
a very very very weird game uh did not
really work out for him and like i said
it all came down to this point after g5
like i believe uh you know
we could try and pinpoint the point of
no return but i believe it was this
moment where duda did not play king to
h8 and after that it was just uh all
oleon and
there was just no no stopping his moves
uh so yeah uh once again hope you guys
enjoyed it we're gonna cover the other
games as well uh i would like to wish
you a very happy birthday to anwar the
95 percent american flag numa and i
would like to thank kaushnik varanzi uh
max beggin uh johan bridger and the
voice of reason consulting llc for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and i will see
you soon continuing the coverage of the
candidates until it finishes uh so thank
you all i will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day